نحن نعلم أن البنتاغون قد طلب
المزيد من هذه الطائرات بدون طيار هذه الطائرات بدون طيار ذات
الشفرات الكهربائية ، وهي في الواقع جيل مختلف
من الطائرات بدون طيار التي
وعدت بالعودة في مارس / آذار ، ما الذي نحتاج
إلى معرفته حول هذه الطائرات
جيدًا ، والسبب في أن الأوكرانيين يقومون بعمل
جيد جدًا.  ثلاثة أشياء رقم
واحد ، إرادة الشعب الأوكراني الذي
يكسبه في تلك الحرب ، والثاني هو
حرب اللوجستيات التي يربحونها في لوجستيات الحرب ،
لقد رأينا كيف
كان أداء الروس
رائعًا وكيف كان أداء الأوكرانيين ببراعة
ولكن الثالث  العنصر هو
التكنولوجيا التي
يستفيد منها الأوكرانيون من التكنولوجيا
التي يستخدمون الطائرات بدون طيار بطريقة لا
تصدق وهذا هو أحد مظاهر أن
هذه الطائرة بدون طيار هذه الطائرة بدون طيار الآن كانت
التكرار الأول هو 300.
هذه ذخيرة صغيرة يتم
إطلاقها من خلال أنبوب
وهذا ليس ذلك حقًا  مهم
ضد أي شيء آخر غير
الأهداف المضادة للأفراد ، هذا هو قاتل الدبابات
وهذا هو نوع
التكنولوجيا التي نحتاجها للوصول إلى هناك
الآن يقوم الأوكرانيون بكونهم
مبتكرين بشكل لا يصدق ،
لديهم أساسًا أعمال ظربان على الطائرات بدون طيار التي
تحدث يومًا بعد يوم ، ولديهم
مختبر عالمي حقيقي ، ولديهم 50 فريقًا
يراقبون الأشخاص الذين كانوا في السابق
من عشاق الطائرات ويجمعونهم
معًا في 50 فريقًا.  يطلقون
300 مهمة في اليوم وهم يقومون
بمعظم أنشطتهم في الليل
، لقد أخذوا 2300
مركبة ميكانيكية
يستخدمون الطائرات بدون طيار لتوفير
الوعي الظرفي
لمدفعيتهم ولأنواع الرمح ، نعم لقد
كان مضاعفًا قتاليًا لا يصدق نحن
بحاجة إلى المزيد من هؤلاء في أيديهم ،
نتحدث عن هذه المنطقة إلى حد كبير ، فنحن نتحدث إلى حد كبير
عن الشرق الأقصى
لأوكرانيا الذي يشمل منطقة الفجر الجهير
هناك سأدفعها حتى
يتمكن الناس من إظهار أنني أستطيع أن أظهر للناس
بالضبط  ما نتحدث عنه حول
ما يريده الروس للخروج من هذا ،
لذا يريد الروس
نقل قواتهم من هنا
للاستيلاء على هذه المنطقة الرئيسية في
نيبرو وإذا كان بإمكانهم ذلك
القوات المتوغلة هنا
تخترق هذا الطريق وتغلق هذه
القوات وتطوق القوات الأوكرانية التي
تدافع عن هذه القوات الأوكرانية ، وقد
قامت بعمل جيد ، لقد أبقت القوات الروسية
الموجودة في هذه المنطقة
ثابتة إلى حد كبير ولكننا نرى القوة الرئيسية
قادمًا من الشمال لمحاولة تطويقهم ،
هذه هي الإستراتيجية النموذجية على
الجبهة الشرقية ، حيث تسير خلفك وتطوقك
وتجبر عدوك على القتال في
اتجاهات 360 درجة حتى يتم
استنفادهم ثم تقترب من هناك
حرب يتم شنها  هنا لمدة ثماني سنوات
حتى يعرف الناس أنه كانت هناك خطوط
هنا حيث كان هناك قتال
ذهابًا وإيابًا منذ أن ضمت روسيا
شبه جزيرة القرم ، لذا فهذه جبهة معركة قديمة ،
نعلم جميعًا أننا نفكر في
ما سيحاول الروس القيام به.
يفعل الأوكرانيون منع هذا
الأمر ، لذا فهم الأوكرانيون أولاً وقبل كل
شيء لديهم خطوط خندق
هنا لديهم ثلاثة خطوط يصعب
الوصول إليها وقد تمسكوا بهذه الخطوط
جيدًا
لكن ما يتعين عليهم فعله هو أنهم
إما أن يعملوا مع القوات
هنا بهذه الطريقة
أو مع القوات القادمة من هنا
عليهم أن يخففوا من حدة هذه الهجمات
وأن يحافظوا على هذه المنطقة مفتوحة ، فهذه قوة
على معركة القوة هذه هي  مناورة الحرب ،
لا يتعلق الأمر بالرجال الذين يختبئون في المنازل
أو خلف الأشجار ويطلقون صواريخ الرمح ،
لذا فإن ما يحتاجونه هو أنهم يحتاجون إلى
دبابات يحتاجون إلى مدفعية متحركة
ويحتاجون إلى
دعم جوي ، وقد نجحت الولايات المتحدة في اختبار صاروخ تفوق سرعة الصوت
كان في منتصف مارس لكنهم كانوا بحاجة
إليه  حافظت على الهدوء لبضعة أسابيع
لتجنب تصعيد التوترات مع روسيا ،
ما رأيك في ذلك ،
لا أعتقد أنه سيلعب كثيرًا
في هذه الحملة على المدى القريب
بريانا ،
لكنني أعتقد أنه بالتأكيد
شيء يمكننا مواجهة
أي شيء  لقد استخدم السيد بوتين أه أنت تعلم
أنه يعتقد أن اختباره الفرط
صوتي قبل عام وربما
استخدام واحد أو اثنين من هؤلاء أه في هذه
الحملة كان سيشكل تهديدًا وإلى
حد ما على
شيء يمكننا  لا تتغلب على
معرفة أن الولايات المتحدة قد اختبرتها
ولديها القدرة على فعل المزيد أه فيما
يتعلق بمخزوناتنا من هذه الأنواع من
الصواريخ وربما غيرها من الصواريخ التي أعتقد
أنك تعرفها هي مواجهة لتهديد السيد بوتين
لا يزال هناك تهديد محتمل
من روسيا لأسلحة الدمار الشامل
الكيميائية والنووية على حد سواء
وعلينا أن نكون قلقين للغاية بشأن
ذلك ولكن كما قال جون كيربي بالأمس
فإن البنتاغون
ووكالات المخابرات يراقبون ذلك
عن كثب لاحتمال حدوث أي
حركة من هذا النوع من الأسلحة